WELCEO "CKERARLSI, AND
TONIT."
LAST NHT, WE TD YOUHE
AUMBE OFECRET BIO LS INUKINE,ABE
CONDTINGXPERENTS ON HIGY
NGERS PAOGEN
WAED TDO. STOR THAASE
WENTACK, W D NOT TNK IT
COD BRUE.
BIRRE.OVETHE-PND
E ADMINTRATN REATEY
AND VE AGGSSIVELY DIED ITH WEREE
TH.
EN THEY AACD AONEHO
KED ESTIONS OUT IS
RUIA.
INSTANCETHEYIGHT BEELLI
E TTH, AND THEN O OF
NOERE, THE BIT ANDFFIAL
IN CRGE OF UAINEONRMED
RIA NULD, THE UERSEETARY
OF STA, CUALL MTION IN
THEENAT HRINGN
BIDEN ADNISTTIONOE FUND AE
SERI OF O LSN UKRNE,AN WTEVER IY
COERD,HESEATERLS WL
LL IO TH HDS OTHE
RUSSNILARY.
DEVELOENT. U AS A SCKIN
OUTO B TRU.TOR THEIRSTTI, WT H E
TORI NAND' TESTIMO RAID
QUESONS: WHA EXALYRETHE LSOING Y
D IOUNAME
AND W DIDT THE BIN
CONTTSF TSE LAB BORE
E RUSSIS IADEDSOAR,E HEN'T RECVY
ANER A A TO THE COND
QUESON.
WE TNK WRE THENLY ES
TH EN ASDT
BIOLIC MATIALITTI IADL
UKINAS RSIANROOP
YETDMITD BORR H NOT
AS THE FST QUEION,HAT
EXACY ISOING ONN THESELA?
WEAVE TTENEVAL AWERS
INITIALL THEDMINTRION
CLAID THE LS WERESIGD
HELUKINIA FIG
BERCOSIS, A WEL AARIO
VESTK SEAS.
THATS WT OFFIALSOLD
MBEROF CONGRS.
DIDT SE PUSIB AND IN
FACT,T IOTLAUSLE.
LAST NIG, THE PENTAN
RELEASEDHAT  NONOTICLY
LLED AACT SHE DESNED TO
SMAL ANDIDICULOURIESEEM
ORGAZAON IAMERA WIOUT
CEPTN REATE THE
ADMISTRAON'S CLAIM VBATIWI NO AY
ND.
FOREIG POLY MAZE RHIS
IDENTICA TO NY OERERSIS
YOU  IF YOUOLW THE NEWS
WORKED T--HE: DO HAS
BU THESEREOT,GAIN INLL
CAPS WEAPONS LABS,SUSSIS
LSEL CLAIMS.
E OFFICL SDOKAY, SO NO BIG DEAL.
THIS I NOTCTLLYHE SRY.
SIE 200ORNG WHING I
BIOLICAL WEAPONSEFTEHIND
BYHEOVIE.
BU WAI 200 W7EARSGO.
HOWONG DST TAKO
IFOU HAD 17EARS ANDMPLE.
PROBLY REMOVAND TALOG
SAMEERIO 17 YEAR TTTCH.
TEST TUB FRO SIET AIN
FREERS.
HOWOES THAWORK ECTLY
WEAVYRE TSE B WEAPONSDO WE LAC N
PACITY T GETHEMUT O
UKINE AND BUR TM IA
SERTNEVA?
WHEN W THEENTAGON PNNING
IN 2 YRS?PORNT J?
THE'SLSO A VY OBVUS
QUESON, BUT N A SINGLERERTERSKEE
ESTIS
ANWHE, OR AT C, PHAPS
ERE E FIT EXPITIOID
ABOU IT,FFER A NEW ABI.ACRDINTOE
LA IUKRAE EXIEDSECUOL SOVTEAPO,A
CURENOT EMINA.
DOEST MN TOECUR A BHA
WEAP?
ANDGAIN WHY H I TAK 1
YEARTO DIT?
ANBY THEAY,F ESE ARE
ALLYUS OLD SIET WPONS
Y ISORIAULAND S WORED
EY WLINDP I T HANDS
OF OLD SIETS?
O PRUMABLY ALRDY HAVE
ESVERYAME WEANS.
PROBLY D'T ND MOR.
'SBSUR WHENOU TNK
OUT .
SO D'T THINKBOUTT.
TODASOVERE OTHE BIDEADNISTTIONEA
BIOL SPITTOP TNKIN
OUT .
ARTCCEPTINGHATHEYELL
ARE A ANT O RUSSIA.YOU
>> T FEBODING MUS,
OHAZARD WNING.
THUSSI STE MEDIA FTAGE
RUNNGACILIESN UKINE IN
GEORGI TT CAUDEADL
FALS B ITAS N STOED ITCKPIT OFHS
TO CIRLATE, ELVINROM BIOGICAAZAR
TOIOLOGICAWEAPS.
KEY PAR O RUSA'S
SINFMAON CPAIG
JUIFYI THE INVIONF
UKINE.
VERAYEARS AGON020,HE
UNIT STASSSUE A STATENT
"SEHE ROR SAIGH"
PLAININGHE FACITIE AREN
TO RORTUTBREAKSAUSEBYE AND
DANGOUSATHOGENS BEFE THEY
POSEECURY ORTALITY
REAT
>> Tucr: TSE CIMSERE
THESE FALITI WORK O
TBAKS. A REPTING
AN THEYLAY RSIANPRAGAN.
THE INT , AONEHOSKS
ESTIONS OUT IS I
GOT?ING RUIAN OPAGANDA
INTESTEDN WHAT RSIANNOT
WE A NOTNTERESTE I WHATH PPAGAIY
ABT THE OLAB.
WE A AMERICA,OE WOD
KE A IN FAC WEHINKE
VE AIGHT T DANDHE BIDADNISTTION,
STIGHTFORWD QSTIO,
BU WHY?R NERVOUSKEORIA
WEON'TNO
THEYON'T ANSR.
OURSELVETO S WHAWE CLD
FIND IHERESHAT W CAME U
TH.
THE DAYFTER RSI INVED
UKRAIN ROBTOPE,HE M
WH HDSHEOOPERATI TEAT
RECTIOPRRAM  DOD SAT
FOR  INTERVI WIT T
WEBSE BLETI OTHE OMIC
HO ISNHAE O LIMING
VI ERAIO WPON S HE
OWA LOBOUT THEUBJE,
Y BEOR TN ANNE EE,
T IT TNS O THANOLL OF
ES SOVIE WEANSRE BNG
DESTROD OR EN SURED AND
PE ACKNOEDGE THA IN THE
TERVIEW.
IC APPENTL CNNID N
SE
ACRDING TOISNTEREW, POPSA THE LN
VIETIO WEAPO PROAM,
RESECHURPOSES. F
POPEAID TT "IENTTS,
BEG SENTIS,T WODN'T
SURPSE M AT SOMOF TSE
RAIN CLEIONS INOMEF
PATHEN SAINS THA GO L THE
WABACKO E OGINSF TH
IN OTH WORDS,ECAUSE A FIVPU IT,A
SCIENTTS,HEY  N WANTO
STROALLHEIO WPONS ANDINEAD E UST
CONDUCNEW O WEAPON
REAR.TH IS WT H SAIAN NOTUST ONO
IN FT, T U.S. EMSSYN  I
"ALE" SCKNOWLEDDOINT
UKRAINIA ANDMERIN REARCH
THERATHOGENS SUC ASHERRHACEVER .
THIS GNG OIN UKRAIUNDEBYHE UTED.
WE DON'TNOW,E CA OYE?
GUS.
DO KNOW TT IN010, THE
U. GERNMT HEED FD THE
COTRUCTIONFRANDEW LEL
REE BIOB I ODE,KRAI.
TO ELIMITE OR SECUR AGIT
SOET WPO, NO, THA L W
DEGNED FOR RESRCN NEW A
"EECIAY DANROUS
PATHENS.
IN UAINEHEOORE CNTRY
BIOMEDAL RESRCH.
WH UKRAINE
WE DON'TNOW.
SOMEE SHLDINDUT.WE D KNO TT T PO
AS FT ON TEVISI TODAY A
ST NHT WEREN UERLI.
DI THE REPTERSHO REPEAD
OSE TALNG POINTERBAM
KNOW TY WE A LIV
MAYBTHEY DID.
ON THE OTH HAND,OW WOULD
THEYNOW?
REPOINHATSVER. TO  ANY
TH GOT TT FM SOME BIDEN
ADNIRATI FLAAND ST
AD IT OTHE R LE  WAS
TR.
U SULDN BE SPRISED
BEUS THAS WT THEY D
AND IT'POSSLE TYRE
AFRAIDOT TDOHAT.
SCRI, THE WTE HSE HAS THE
AS POOLSF PIN. BEFG ROOM
HE IS BEN'SUBLIST DNG
TH VER SAM THINGODAY>> TAI ISS D
TWIER TEADESTEAY WAS
AT RSIAAS AISTORY AO
OFNVENTINGUTGHTIES KE
IS WHI IS E SUESTION
THAT T UNID STES H
CHEMICALND BLOGIL APON
OGRA ORKRNEOES,HAT
THEYRE OPERANG.
RUIAS THE O,S TH
COUNY TH H CHEMICA AND
BIOLICALEANS PROAM,O
E OBJTIVE W TO MAK CLE
E INAURY OFHE
FORMION,HEISINRMATN
EY WE TRYINGO P O,
MA CLEAR TT TH NOTNLY
HAVE T CAPITY,HEYAVE A
HIORY OFSINGHEMIL D
BIOGIC WEANS,NDHATN
ISOMEN WE SULDAV OEY OPE>>ucke .
BUT N ONE DIES THATH'S T THI.
BI PROAM, THASAD. CAN
NONEENIE THA RUSSIA LIEOFOURS AG
THATUSSI PROGANDA I
ABLUTS
THAT N UP FOR DEBE.
AT'SLLRUE.THUESTION IS, WHY IS E
UNED STES FUNDG TSE
OLS TT ARE NOTOING
ANYTNGLO T WHAT T
PENTON CIMS EY ARE DNG?
Y IS THEHITEOUSE
DIREORF TH PENGON' B THE
WHY ISHE DOI TT, A HOW
OU W FL AUT AF
THIS?
SUED, T AL VER
THERD.